إن طعن شاب
أمريكي من أصل فلسطيني يبلغ من العمر 23 عامًا يتوافق مع
تعريف جريمة الكراهية وفقًا
لقسم شرطة أوستن. ويوافق زكريا على أن
هذه الجريمة ضده كانت
بدافع الكراهية. كنت الوحيد
هناك الذي كان لديه علم فلسطين و
CFA معلقًا.  من النافذة جاء على
وجه التحديد إلى باب منزلي وقام بتخديري
من السيارة، حدث الطعن يوم
الأحد بعد مسيرة مؤيدة للفلسطينيين
في أوستن عندما قال تور إن
المشتبه به بيرت جيمس بيكر اقترب من
سيارته ونظرت حولي ولم أر
شيئًا
وبعد ذلك  لقد
فتح باب منزلي رجل مجنون وسحبني
من شاحنتي. طعن لور في
الجانب الأيسر من ظهره وأصيب
بكسر في أحد أضلاعه وهو الآن قلق بشأن رعاية
ابنه البالغ من العمر خمسة أشهر، وهذه واحدة من
أعظم أفراحي القادمة  منزل ابني
وتم أخذه
مني، لم أتمكن من اصطحاب
ابني، كن هناك من أجل
ابني وافعل أي شيء من أجله خلال
اليومين الماضيين، يعتقدنا نحن
السياسيون بما في ذلك حاكم ولاية تكساس
جريج أبوت والرئيس جو بايدن
يجب أن يدعوا إلى وقف إطلاق النار إذا
صعد هذان الشخصان
وقالا شيئًا للوقوف إلى جانبنا، وقالا
شيئًا للدفاع
عنا، لم يكن هذا
ليحدث أبدًا، ولكن
لأنهم لم يقولوا شيئًا لنا،
فهذا هو السبب في أنني لست
الأول  أنا لست الثاني، ولست حتى
الثالث، فكم من الأشخاص
يجب أن يستمروا حتى
يدركوا أن هذا خطأ، ويقول إن هذا
الهجوم لن يمنعه من الدفاع
عن شعب غزة، وأتمنى حقًا
أن يفعل الناس ذلك  ندرك
أنه عندما نخرج إلى هناك ونحتج،
فهذا لا يعني التسبب في مشكلة، بل إنه إنهاء
المشكلة، وهذه هي المشكلة في غزة.
شيء كهذا لن
يمنعني من
الدفاع عن شعبي